And everybody, Dr. Cutters, again, this video is talking about a step number one.
This is really your first step, and starting to get a handle on your autoimmune disease.
And it's an honest, self-assessment of triggers.
So this is where it does become difficult, because sometimes we don't know what's triggering
it.
And we want to always go to your history of that honest assessment, self-assessment of trying
to figure this out.
What is triggering this thing?
And this is where testing is so invaluable, because it can tell us, you know, the triggers
that you don't always see.
Remember, these are IgA reactions that are typically an IgE immediate response, where it's like
eating the peanut and your throat starts to close off.
It's, you know, eating gluten, and you don't notice any symptoms for, you know, 16 to 20
hours.
How are you going to notice if this is a trigger for your autoimmune disease?
It's difficult.
So I'm not making this step easy, but I'm saying that we do need to dig into this.
We need to figure this out.
What are my triggers that are firing off my immune reaction?
So this is the clinical management that we're talking about.
First piece, what are some different possible foods, some different possible chemicals, pathogens,
stressors, sleep issues?
We need to dig into all these different things for a self-assessment standpoint, and then later
possibly if we can to do some testing to fine-tune what is firing these reactions.
So first autoimmunity, it can be fired by dietary proteins.
So if I have self-antibodies, antibodies to self-tissue, let's say I have antibodies to my thyroid
gland, therefore I have Hashimoto's disease, anything that I eat, if I have antibodies to
that dietary protein in that food, and I'm going to fire up an immune reaction because
I ate that food, it's going to then attack my thyroid gland.
So if I fire an immune response, I am going to kill, I will destroy, my immune system will
destroy that, which I have antibodies against first.
So if I have antibodies against my thyroid, and I also have antibodies against gluten, and
I'm eating gluten, I'm firing this immune reaction in my gut, it's causing inflammation in my
gut, causing damage in my gut, causing damage in my brain, inflammation in my brain, but
it's also damaging my thyroid simply because I'm creating an immune response when I have
self-antibodies to a tissue.
So that's why it's important to look for these triggers, that's why it's important to assess
food intake.
If I have antibodies to different foods, and it's typically the proteins, or the peptides
of the food, then I will destroy tissue when I eat foods that I have these antibodies against.
I can't overemphasize this, you know, I have a bunch of videos on this, and I'm not trying
to scare you, but you've got to deal with this.
So it's not even just what I just said, it's also cross-reacted foods, and cross-reacted
immune reactions, and it gets even more complicated, it can be different, combine the foods.
You can have a reaction to cooked corn, or cooked carrots, and not to raw carrots, or vice versa.
That's why it's good to do a test, but I don't, we can't do a test, I always try to look
at self-assessment here, try to make this easy peasy, try to look at self-assessment.
In another video, you'll see that sodium salt can be a major trigger for autoimmune disease,
if you haven't seen that video catch that video, because that's a hidden thing, that's not
an immune reaction, that's not a sensitivity, like I have antibodies to sodium, it's simply
this reaction that takes place in a certain percentage of people that have an autoimmune disease.
When they eat salt, it fires an attack on that organ, it's crazy, I know, it gets depressing,
it's like, I can't salt my food, I'll take all the joy out of my life, but is that, this
early, you have to stay away from it for life, because it doesn't mean you have to stay away
from it completely, it's impossible to, we do need sodium, but understanding that that
could be a trigger, look at that boy, what I do, that is it, I couldn't figure out which
food it is, if I thought it was corn or the corn chips, maybe it's the salt.
And sugar spikes, sugar imbalances, glucose imbalances in my bloodstream affect my autoimmune
issue, yes, so look at that boy, I thought it was the dairy in that brownie, and it's actually
the sugar in that brownie, that's spiked a glucose reaction, that's spiked a reaction
to my body, food coloring, huge stay, additives in colories are huge, not just for kids, but these
are huge inflammatory markers, especially with rate inflammation, geobulsant activity, pesticides,
things like that, all these can ramp up my immune response, the most common of these are
gluten, dairy, corn, egg, with thyroid issues, you've got molecular mimicry going on with
gluten and the thyroid, so that is just, I mean if you have Hashimoto's, nobody with Hashimoto's
should be gluten, just cross that off your list, period, there's just no exception there, I don't
care if you did a food, had to if I did test it, it was negative for gluten, it's a molecular
mimic to the thyroid gland, so you have circulated peptides, glyaden peptides, it's going to
fire a reaction in your immune system, and it's going to kill thyroid tissue, so nobody with
thyroid issues, or I should say everybody that has an autoimmune thyroid, whether it be graves
or Hashimoto's has got to be gluten free, dairy, molecular mimics with dairy and gluten cross
reactants with dairy gluten are very common, corn, egg, nightchains, especially with arthritis,
like rheumatoid, psoriatic arthritis, very, very common, the nightchains are a major cause of
inflammation there, sugar that I just talked about, glutamates in food, huge things, especially if you
have genetic conversion issues with the GAN genes and the other glutamate genes that converts glutamate,
which is an amino acid, found in a lot of different things, and our proteins that we're eating
converts it readily to glutamate, glutamate becomes a neurotransmitter, and it's an excitatory
neurotransmitter, causes a lot of brain inflammation and a lot of issues, food additives, colorings,
pesticides, chemicals that we're exposed to, these are all possible triggers, these are the things
you want to look at and do an honest self-assessment of these things, sensitivity to chemicals and
reaction to chemicals can be because of impaired hepatic biotransformation that's a fancy way of
saying issues with my detox pathways in my liver, impaired microbiome biotransformation, fancy way of
saying issues with my phase four, five, and six detox pathways, if you don't know what that is,
look at the detox course read my book on the phases of detoxification, I'll have more information
in this course on that as well, depletion of antioxidants, antioxidants are the sole purpose of helping
to prevent oxidation, so chemicals in our environment, why are they damaging to us, they
cause oxidizing reactions to ourselves, these are major cancer causers, okay, that's our major
major population is cancer, people you've got to be understanding that this is a major, if not
the most common cause of cancer, is lack of antioxidants and exposure to oxidizing agents,
these are found in your cosmetics, found in your clean supplies, BPA plastics,
formaldehydes, glues, benzines, from smoke, cigarette smoke, car exhaust, pesticides, herbicides,
these are the most common things that we see, a huge issue need to deal with these things and
notice exposure to these things and cut down on exposure to these things even if you don't feel like
that they're triggers, so we're looking for triggers here again, any other triggers, immune triggers,
how common have I heard that boy after I got sick, after I got COVID, after I got this vaccine, after
I got another tick bite, this flared the whole thing, I went into a moldy room and it flared the
whole thing and it made everything worse, very, very common to have susceptibility to pathogens where
causes reactivity and of latent immune issues and latent viral issues, can stimulate an
abstinement virus, issue can stimulate a live issue that had been latent for a long period of time,
very, very common look for these types of triggers, stresses so often overlooked but it is because
it's just kind of normal that we have such work demands on us, we put such work demands on us
and we just kind of overlook it, don't overlook unhealthy relationships, don't overlook
sleep issues and talk a little bit more about that in a second, not having friends, your Facebook
friends are not your friends, you have to have close interpersonal relationships, studying
under study, after study, talk about close interpersonal relationships, get involved in a church,
get involved in a support group, get involved in a community of other people that like to do the
things that you like to do, that can make the greatest difference on your autoimmune responses and
how your body can balance this, talk about personal susceptibility, this is a key component to that,
increase stress decreases, your immune response can increase your risk of cancer,
increases your risk of all sorts of toxicity issues because neurologically your parasympathetic
control, parasympathetic nervous system controls your liver detoxification pathways,
and when you're under a sympathetic demand, maybe you're under a hyper stress demand all the time,
your parasympathetics are going to be imbalanced, suppressed, your pathways, your neurological pathways
are going to be depressed, healthy immune response is going to be depressed and your susceptibility
to all sorts of disease, including cancer goes way up, so can't overemphasize that,
assess them on a sleep you're getting, are you really getting adequate sleep, you feel guilty for
taking naps, are you getting deep sleep, are you feeling rested when you wake up, there's issues
that can be with your cortisol, your needles, your pituitary thyroid, access that can cause all this,
it can be as simple as I need to start, I need some protein before I go to bed to I need to really get
hormones checked through a full-dutch panel and see what is really causing this, and
it can be as simple as dealing with that, but not getting enough sleep can kill you literally,
so you really need to look at that and be honest with yourself about that as well.
I talked about exercise and overexercising, certainly under exercising is a major component,
you know, you have a set of Terry lifestyle, you're not out doing anything, that's not going to help
anybody, but overexercising can be equally a problem, so if you are thinking that exercise and you
grew up in a lifestyle that you were very athletic and you think that's going to be your solution,
I'm going to just try and start training for a marathon or something like that, if you,
especially if you have any type of brain inflammation, any microglial primate in the brain, certainly
neural antibody formation, you can't overexercise, you've got to go really slow, so make sure that you keep
a balance with that. With all of this, when we assess this, everybody's completely different,
you know, some people are going to react to different things, you know, I can't go into a house with
mold in it, oh, if I grew to it, just tips me over, but, you know, food colour, it just throws me off.
Wow, if I give my kid, you know, something with Terry, it just completely blows them out.
Everybody's going to be different with that, that's what this whole idea is,
fighting out what, where your balance is, so that you can manage the best way you can,
because that's really what we're talking about, it's lifestyle and managing this and keeping
this balance, try to keep your autoimmune disease in a state of remission, it's not talking about
curate, it's balancing this and remission, hey, I could live this way, but also to have enjoyed
your life, we don't want you to eliminate everything in your diet, not have any joy in your life,
but you have to get into balance, that's the whole key. So that's what we're studying, we're continuing
to study, know that I'm praying for you and you're praying for me, I hope to, and we'll see you in the
next video, bye bye.